yeah I was just looking your beans it's
a great accessory basically we've become
Craig from Ninja Turtles where she's the
brain and I'm just the operation you're
not a man of them know it look it up
dicks this is mamrie Hart if you did not
know we are here to give you guys some
advice on your life
groundbreaking I've done this before I
think one of my favorite videos I've
ever done with you is spaghetti in bed
in Austin what does it take to be in a
dough
come again I spaghetti in bed how do you
think you would survive in the hunger
game absolutely not I hit myself over
the head with a rock immediately Cheers
we are drinking because we are
celebrating that we are going to go up
to Canada we're going up to Montreal for
just relax we're hosting a show called
all-access all-access live baby Thursday
night is two shows with a ton of
comedian so many comedians yet hosting
ever doing a little bit in the show and
we'll be like peppered throughout the
whole of both of the shows so come see
it if you are in Montreal link is in the
description so you can buy tickets yeah
come we want to see our little weird
echo a Montreal Lights
mantri of
entre list yeah montréal in my dreams we
want to see real faces
now I won my Facebook and I asked you
guys for any questions you had that we
might be able to give you advice on so
we're going to go through those right
now let's see what we got let's turn to
my color I thought it was a great color
I don't look like I have like jaundice
while you have a shaking dog in your lap
that dog looks like I have dramas I will
say that I carry beans around me like
this because I just look a little more
attractive this Gary Gallagher Beth
belong or wants to know advice you're
trying 3000
perfect because dirty thirty the movie
that name we wrote and that we are all
in comes out September 23rd right now
and there's a lot of I think like
subliminal advice for you I mean there's
a lot of advice throughout it okay
here's my advice a lot of people freaked
out that 30 is supposed to represent
like finally being an adult or like now
I'm hold over the hill where's my like
fart pills and came with a horn from
Party City
my favorite Department people assume 30
is a red flag for crisis like you're
supposed to freak out so I think that
you should on your 30th birthday do
something even more silly and childish
than normal like you were at my 30th
birthday party was a weapons party I was
dressed like a ninja
we had blow dart pellet gun a rope swing
do something like out-of-the-box
immature to remind yourself that this
isn't the end it's just the beginning I
spaghetti in bed and then laying time is
an illusion anyway so what age are any
of us I'm 32 I will that 3 it is an
ellipse
Deborah head of barn innocent number and
it is a great first date with someone
love you ladies love you to Jennifer and
theirs first tip don't tell them you
love them wear something that you are
comfortable in I would say I'm kind of a
flip tip from that you look good feel
comfortable that's a clip tip you'll
flip down we're not cute panties because
you should make sure there's at least
some sort of speed bump and like
naked on the first day that's your
version of a chastity belt it's like are
your period pennies but that is the
modern-day chastity belt salad is the
worst thing to eat on a date you know
why because I recently was out to dinner
with the male and was eating a salad
and it was endive uh-huh which is
delicious but like they were this big
yeah and you're just sitting there
looking like you're eating like small
like you know like toy boats yeah or
just like we need vegetables while
vegetable wean sounds like a children's
book where someone gives out vegetables
to trick-or-treaters that awful fate of
all it wasn't like look like Queens and
a fun like suggestive way no this really
like I broke my mouth this behavior
though you get won by their real Sondra
Townsend gamergate I'm from the south I
live in Mississippi what's your favorite
drink for a hot southern summer oh when
I'm on my back porch ah girl julep I
think the best trick is infusing vodkas
with tea I know they make like sweet tea
vodka and whatever but no you just take
any maca and throw in some like
delicious like passionfruit ki or
regular to your whatnot give it 15
minutes I don't taste like vodka that's
the biggest lesson I've learned on why -
other than just like lighting and also
hitting record wanna call memory cab
fusing alcohol seems really complicated
but it's actually so insanely simple and
the result is delicious you can really
impress people by doing very little and
I is what I've learned in life that's
not like what we strive to do every day
or all day long throw a tea bag on it so
as I said how do we just go for your
dreams I'm inspired by so many people
and things but I can't commit to
creating easier said than done but you
just have to like do it yeah there's
whole books about this so I don't know
if we'll be able to wrap it up right now
you need to figure out what the dream is
you're gonna have to have so much
passion and further behind it for it to
ever come true yeah you can't be you
have to be specific with it it will be
like I'd like to be a writer
great
what do you want to write I know one
thing I'd like get as far whittled as
you can you don't think it so specific
cuz your dreams can change but I feel
like it'll come through doing you can
say I want to be the Michelin star chef
and then as soon as you start working in
a kitchen you realize you can mean it
decide on something go for it start
getting experience in that area and then
figure I mean used to figure it out from
there there's only a matter of trial and
actual error Whittle it a little bit but
also just do it I mean like I think of
Michael Jordan and Nikes trademarking
like just do it
swoosh mark baby there's our sponsor for
this episode ally Cain wants to know
finally we go with your period at your
boyfriend's but it's the first time you
spend the night with him wear those ugly
panties that's a great way to tell like
if you're a girl with a guy or girl the
girl like if they're a good person to be
like hey I got my period
you can speak openly about your period I
mean you don't have to like give them a
descriptive essay we all are here right
now because a woman was getting their
period everybody know someone who does
it yeah he does know someone that does
it not being does know oh my god could
you imagine tampon eating cat Casarez
where to aim fart in public ha ha ha
I would say aim that at anyone publicly
playing Pokemon go oh good idea
you know pokemons gone I've been waiting
for the mamrie Hart
just break down you know I don't I don't
get it at all all I know is that it is
up to the amount of like creepy dudes by
themselves walking around my
neighborhood at night by like a zillion
and I don't like it I think there should
be a Pokemon go curfew like Pokemon go
home based on your time zone they're
like sorry I'm a Pokemon point
sleep wake up tomorrow no no no give up
or hope Iman to me whenever I hear it to
me it just sounds like a Jamaican man
ordering Auggie tuna like an ahi tuna
bowl I'll take the Pokemon
that's my dad yeah if you guys want to
see more jokes like that coach why I
like this live uh montréal just relapsed
I can hear people asking for refunds so
and they check over to memories Channel
and check out all of our wonderful
videos but also we did a video a quick
shot that's going to go up over there
these do you have anything final
thoughts let your phone numbers on this
oh thanks my gosh I resist
I don't know anything that involves some
sort of carbohydrate being eaten ball
laying down mm-hmm I'm on board with
it's my favorite sport
I like to carbo-load to sleep